un délinquant arrêté une GPA abrogé à
parquet à poser une fosse septique à
purger valse répare valse remplace
et maintenant j'accueille Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis en train de garder un chat
à la maison
qu'est-ce qui me saoule
heureusement qu'il y a Farid là Stanley
Kubrick des quartiers Nord vient de
faire une vidéo qu'est-ce que ça m'a
fait du bien de voir
bon le pauvre il s'est pris un en tôle
mais ça c'est ce qui s'est mal défendu
c'est très mal défendu il aurait dû
surfer sur les sujets du moment c'est il
aurait pu dire moi je veux bien mais moi
je vois bien madame le juge mais j'ai un
moustache qui pousse je mue je sens le
fauve je crois j'ai un problème
d'identité je n'arrive pas à accepter
peut-être je suis un chat miaou
peut-être que je me venge
j'hésite madame je suis un chaton ou un
mannequin Coq Sportif je sais pas j'ai
jamais connu ma mère c'est peut-être
voilà je je me cherche
alors le vrai sujet de la semaine bien
sûr c'est un faux il paraît que Hollande
n'a pas revu Julie Gayet depuis qu'il a
rompu avec Pierre Belair
alors j'ai vu de révélère en couverture
de match tu as l'impression qu'elle a
avalé Jeanne Calment
en tout cas moi je suis très inquiet
pour François face et tu vois enfin
quand tu es un chaud lapin un mois
d'abstinence ça commence à faire
beaucoup
alors je sais qu'il va aux États-Unis
bientôt moi j'éviterai le Sofitel
[Applaudissements]
sinon quoi d'autre elle va du classique
vous avez commencé à aborder la question
comme toutes les semaines la République
est menacée par la peste brune les
forces réactionnaires les heures sombres
de l'histoire Dark Vador Hannibal Lecter
Caroline forest c'est
devenu un classique c'est c'est bien
simple aujourd'hui si t'es pas un
gauchiste enragé ou un facho tu as
l'impression d'être Nana Mouskouri
coincé entre les Stone c'est les Sex
Pistols
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je dis pas les années 30 sale
période surtout en 33 l'assassinat du
Christ
pourquoi ils ont dénoncé
c'était un mec chouette quoi
en tout cas finalement le gouvernement a
retiré sa loi sur la famille enfin le
gouvernement bon Valls en ce moment il
fait tout plutôt que faire premier flic
de France il aurait dû ouvrir un service
de conciergerie
un délinquant arrêté une GPA abrogée à
parquet à poser une fosse septique à
purger valse répare Vals remplace
polémique alors forcément dans un climat
pareil c'est très propice aux rumeurs
alors depuis deux semaines grosse
campagne de manipulation c'est
l'histoire des fameux textos qu'on
envoie aux parents pour dire qu'on
apprend aux enfants à se masturber à
l'école alors j'ai fait mon enquête je
suis allé sur le site de l'éducation
nationale rubrique ABCD de l'égalité
alors je confirme effectivement ce que
j'ai lu c'est vraiment de la branlette
mais attention de place internationale à
côté le Congrès mondial des enculeurs de
mouches c'est du sérieux
alors le but de la démarche je cite je
cite c'est proposer des activités qui
procurent des émotions inhabituelles et
qui vont à l'encontre des stéréotypes
sexistes exemple je cite toujours de la
course d'orientation pour combattre
l'idée que les filles sont peureuses
elles ne savent pas s'orienter refaire
le compte du chaperon rouge en mettant
des hommes dans le rôle du chaperon
rouge et des filles dans le rôle du loup
on propose même des pistes d'ouverture à
l'égalité avec cette lecture c'est
l'album d'Hector l'homme
extraordinairement fort je cite Hector
l'homme extraordinairement fort est
capable de choses époustouflante
pourtant une fois son numéro terminé
Hector est un homme discret il a
installé sa caravane à l'écart loin des
regards car il a secret il tricote
[Applaudissements]
autre exemple d'activité la GRS
gymnastique rythmique et sportive avec
un ruban alors le but
je cite faire faire des activités qui
permettent aux filles de prendre des
risques avec un objet qui les attire
et aux garçons d'être dans une activité
esthétique tout en prenant des risques
corporels
[Applaudissements]
de la GRS esthétique mon fils et tu
donneras des coups de boule ma fille
et ainsi ils affront la mondialisation
alors certains dénoncent le lobby LGBT
bon moi je connaissais pas jusque là
LGBT je pensais que c'était un peu une
banque de sperme au Luxembourg tu vois
c'est en fait c'est l'abréviation de
lesbien gay transbis c'est d'un
triste
non mais tu rajoutes la lettre S pour
sclérose en plaques et p comme
philatélie tu comprends pourquoi ils
sont souvent seuls dans les manifs
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas pour critiquer enfin vous
peut-être lesbienne
parce que les rubans ça va perdure
une discussion dans les couples lesbiens
ou gay sur l'enfance et moi je les envie
c'est les seuls couples on peut pas te
faire un enfant dans le dos
[Rires]
tu as pigé laquelle en fait
France Montebourg Arnaud Montebourg
exige que Google domicili s'est donné en
France vous avez bien entendu Arnaud
menace Google
tu sais qui va pas arriver à s'asseoir
pendant 3 jours
en fait c'est le Chuck Norris français
tu remplaces Chuck Norris par Montebourg
dans les blagues sur Chuck Norris ça
fonctionne pareil exemple si la courbe
du chômage ne s'est pas inversée c'est
parce qu'elle attend car nous mon bourg
lui donne l'ordre
Arnaud Montebourg c'est où se trouve le
papa de Stromae
a un mixeur lui suffit
bonne nouvelle merci ça a été donc il y
a 4 jours journée de prévention du
suicide alors cette année le
gouvernement a mis le paquets ils
envoyaient des textos aux gens qui
avaient un dossier un peu lourd alors je
te lis le texto c'est ne t'inquiète pas
je suis là signé Jean-Marc Hérault
alors pas belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu